the special effects man at the studio  almost plays God volcanoes erupt at his  bidding tidal waves come and go  earthquakes quake it's all in a day's  work  but what happens to such a man when he  comes home to the little woman why did I  have a day ah tell mommy the Red Sea  wouldn't part some not defrosted Siberia  and Mount Vesuvius backed up what a  coincident so did the sink well don't  look at me call a plumber  call a plumber me the wife of the  miracle worker special effects are  make-believe plumbing is real and real  too is the ingenuity of the men  responsible for the nominated special  visual effects Ice Station zebra Hal  Millar and J Macmillan John 2001 a space  of Stanley Kubrick the winner is Stanley  Cooper  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  mr. Kubrick unfortunately cannot be with  us tonight  so we'll have as Oscar delivered  tomorrow where he is scouting locations  for 2002 Space Odyssey revisited